Scrabble is not just
a simple word game,
it requires strategy
and an understanding of
mathematics and probability.
Here are five tips
to improve your game.
There are 124 two-letter words
allowed in Scrabble.
Try to learn as many of them
as you can -
even if they look a bit weird.
Then play them parallel to your
opponent's word to score big points.
If you play all seven letters in one
turn, you get an extra 50 points.
How can you improve your chances
of getting a bonus?
Keep good combinations of
one-point tiles on your rack,
especially those in the word...
These six letters go with
every letter of the alphabet
except for Q and Y,
to make a seven-letter word.
A hook is a letter that can be added
to the front or end
of a word to make a new one.
S is the most obvious.
But there are many less obvious ones
you can use to surprise your opponent
with a high-scoring play.
Practice anagramming
whenever you can.
Cryptic crosswords
and puzzles can help.
Sometimes normal words
can be surprisingly hard to spot.
Don't be frightened to exchange
some or all of your tiles
rather than playing a word.
It can be the best thing to do.
High-scoring tiles
are not always good.
From an opening rack like this, there
is nothing you can usefully play.
Exchange six tiles
and just keep the letter E.
Ah now that looks a lot better!
Follow these tips and you'll
find yourself winning
a lot more than you lose.
Even though it certainly feels great,
winning isn't everything,
don't forget to have fun.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)